les yôkai sont tout autour de nous mais
personne sur cette terre ne peut les
voir sauf un jeune garçon ressemble
comme deux gouttes d'eau à ton grand
père qui l'avait ton âge même si c'était
un garçon qui avait aussi ceux qui sous
écoute moins attentivement le monde
court un grand danger
well well mayuka l'ouest les perfides
ont remonté le temps et changer le cours
de l'histoire et aujourd'hui c'est comme
si la youkai watch n'avait jamais existé
bien d'autres choses et toutes les
personnes auxquelles tu tiens dans ce
monde disparaîtront alors nous pouvons
toujours remonter le temps jusqu'à son
époque
nathaniel je te présente nathan tout
petit fils
non
maxime aso c'est lui mon grand-père
natanya licencie finissent de fabriquer
la uk wax dans le futur les yôkai watch
a cessé d'exister parce que tu as arrêté
de la mettre au point alors mon concept
va fonctionner si tu achètes la
conception de la montre
ensemble nous viendrons à bout des
pépites
[Musique]
la nuit elle est faite celle-là you can
watch ne sera jamais fabriqué
l'attaquant canadien
massacrer les pédales
ça va venir
on dit ça
pour maîtriser des barres de chocolat